the church fathers used the greek
philosophy and aquinas uses aristotle
and all that's great but we're an
historical religion and that matters
immensely
is the bible
the literal word of god how do you make
sense of the words that make up the
bible i think the best way to get at the
bible is to think of it as a library not
a book so it's a collection of books
right from a wide variety of periods
different authors different audiences
and different genre
so in the bible you find poetry you find
song you find something like history not
in our sense but something like history
you find gospel it's his own genre you
find
epistolary literature like paul you find
apocalyptic
there's all this in the bible
so is the bible literally the word of
god it's like saying is is the library
uh literally true it depends on what
section you're in right so
parts of like one and two samuel one and
two kings uh
number places the old testament are
there elements of the historical in
there sure but it's theologically
interpreted history it's not like our
sense of history of you know give me ten
thousand footnotes and you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna um look at all the
source material i can possibly find it's
more like ancient history uh like
herodotus people like that
um but then there's poetry and there's
myth and there's legend and there's song
and all that stuff in the bible so
god breathes through all of it i would
say
he inspired all of it right inspira he's
he's breathing through all of it god is
speaking through all of it but he speaks
in different voices uh he uses different
human instruments and he uses different
genre in different types of language so
we have to be sensitive to that when
we're interpreting the bible so the
different instruments are more or less
uh some are more perfect than others no
i wouldn't say that it wasn't more
perfect i'd say they're just different
it's like a symphony and god's like a
conductor and there's all kinds of
different instruments in the orchestra
and he loves us to breathe through the
psalms i prayed the psalms this morning
i do every day in my in my office you
know that's those are songs they
probably were literally sung most of
them at one point he breathes through um
apocalyptic like we're reading the book
of revelation now in the easter season
and this wild and woolly
book it should be filmed by you know
spielberg or somebody today and he
speaks through the gospels
the gospels which correspond in general
to what i call ancient biography
that's the genre of the gospels it's
wrong to call them like mythic or simply
literary they're like ancient
biographies
you have the pauline letters which are
about in all particular cities that paul
was visiting and particular people he
knew so you just got to be sensitive to
the genre all the time
you